Voiceover: So I'm here with
famous filmmaker Davis Guggenheim.
Davis: I'm smirking when
you say this famous-
Voiceover: You are!
"Inconvenient Truth,"
"Waiting for Superman," a great
teacher's project, amongst others.
Just to rewind I'd like to talk
frankly about all of the stuff
that you've worked on, but
how did you get started?
I've always been fascinated when
I see people who are filmmakers,
there's not a traditional
career, how did you get started?
Davis: My father was
a great documentarian.
No one knew who he was.
He rode his bike to work
but he made all these great
social justice documentaries
and he was my hero.
But after college I moved to
L.A. to not make documentaries.
Voiceover: What did you do in college?
What did you think you were going to do?
Davis: I was a history major and I
wanted to get out of my father's shadow.
And I moved up to Hollywood, I'm
not going to make documentaries.
Voiceover: But did you have an
idea of what you were going to do?
Davis: I was going to
make Hollywood movies.
I was going to be, he makes documentaries,
I want to be a hot shot
Hollywood director.
Voiceover: But you had embraced
this film-making aspect of your-
Davis: Yes.
Voiceover: That's not
as big of a departure,
for most people that
seems still pretty close.
Davis: So kids of doctors
can become a lawyer,
you know kids of lawyers
can become an accountant,
but no one is the kid of a
documentarian and becomes a doctor.
It's a degenerative
skill that's passed down.
You never go back.
Voiceover: I don't understand that right.
(Davis laughs)
Is it because your father would have
judged you if you would have become
Davis: No.
Davis: No, no.
I don't think I could have, frankly.
I think, very dyslexic,
not good in school.
And so I became tuned to other things.
My brain was tuned to other things.
Voiceover: So you saw your
father and you saw film crews
Davis: Right.
Davis: It's like growing up in the circus.
Voiceover: In a good way.
Davis: Yeah, lights, cables,
cameras, that's cool.
Voiceover: What your father did
did strongly influence this-
Davis: Yes.
Davis: And he was a hero to me.
I just could never been as good as him.
Imagine if your hero was Superman or Iron
Man, you'll never be as good as that.
Voiceover: So you thought
that it would be amazing to be
a great documentarian like my dad but
I'm never going to be able to do that.
Davis: He won 4 Academy
Awards, was nominated 12 times.
Voiceover: So you started off
saying no one knows who he is
and he rides his bike to
work and now, he was a big-
Davis: But no one knew who he
was so he had the double threat
of being totally anonymous but
also remarkable in what he did.
Voiceover: What were some of his most-?
Davis: He made films about the Johnstown
flood, the Ku Klux Klan, the Kennedys.
Voiceover: Are those
out there, can people-
Davis: Yeah, I'll give you copies of it.
Beautiful movies, beautiful movies.
Voiceover: Can we include
them on Khan Academy?
Davis: Of course.
Beautiful wonderful movies.
Voiceover: And so you view
that as like the high watermark
and you could do that but you could
do a big Hollywood blockbuster?
Davis: Right, and it's more like...
we talked about this earlier,
the son finding his identity
outside of his father.
Like you know, just to follow in his
footsteps would have been pathetic
for me as an 18 year old.
So I had to go off and make it on my own.
Voiceover: But how did you think about it?
Did you think what are my odds
on being able to succeed here?
Davis: Yes, I did the math.
Impossible.
Voiceover: And so you
still decided to do it?
Davis: Oh you mean to go to Hollywood?
Voiceover: Well filmmaker
generally, Hollywood in particular.
Davis: Yeah but like the odds of me being
a doctor or lawyer was worse. (laughs)
So it was like it was not even possible.
There were no odds.
Voiceover: So you weren't naive.
Davis: It's like the Mets
winning the world series.
Voiceover: You knew, so
this was right after college
Davis: Yeah.
Voiceover: Where did you go to college?
Davis: I went to NYU and then Brown.
Voiceover: NYU and Brown and so
history, what did you do at Brown?
Davis: And I remember walking around
the campus at Brown senior year
going documentaries are kind of
over, Ken Burns is Ken Burns,
there's no place for me.
Like it'll never... like the
establishment is there and it's set.
Things will never change.
Voiceover: So you started at
NYU, transferred to Brown.
You were a history major the entire
time but film was always in your mind?
Davis: I went to NYU to study film.
Voiceover: Right, they're famous for that.
Davis: And after a year I said I
don't like this, it's not for me.
I'm going to study history.
Because I think NYU at the time
was very practically based,
it was teaching a lot of skills a
lot of my fellow students really dug
and learned from but I knew and
from what my father taught me
that the key piece, which is the
ultimate thing to learn, is storytelling.
And I wasn't seeing anyone
who taught storytelling
so why not learn history
where the great...
And my father sort of influenced
me and said if you learn to write,
if you read a lot, if you
sort of figure that part out,
then you can figure out stories.
But the path to becoming a good
filmmaker is not about the equipment
or the technique, it's about stories.
Voiceover: And so when you were
sitting in a history class in Brown
and one of your friends says hey,
I'm going to apply for grad school
in history or I'm applying for a
job in Wall Street or whatever,
you would say oh well, I'm
going to go to Hollywood.
Davis: Yeah.
Voiceover: Even though you were studying
history that film was your thing?
Davis: Yep.
Voiceover: And when you say the odds
I think you're being a little bit
faux-humble that you couldn't
have been a doctor, right?
Davis: I couldn't have been-
Davis: Very dyslexic, very dyslexic.
Voiceover: But you transferred
to... well I won't push something.
Davis: I couldn't have done, what's
the big chem course, I guess-
Voiceover: Organic chemistry.
Davis: I mean not even close.
Davis: Not even close, not even close.
I in fact wiggled my way
through passing the key things
and Brown had no core curriculum.
So I wiggle my way through high
school and I worked really hard
to get sort of a C minus average.
I'm not boasting.
I'm not boasting in my
lack of intelligence.
Voiceover: But then you happened to get
in one of the most selective universities?
Davis: NYU was very easy
to get into in 1982.
Davis: Very easy.
Davis: And then I transferred
to Brown after I did really well
Voiceover: I see.
Davis: I was ambitious
but not a good student.
Voiceover: So anyway, (Davis
laughs) so you get to Hollywood...
I'm suspicious of all of this.
Davis: It's absolutely true.
I really could not have
been a doctor or a lawyer.
Voiceover: And then you go to Hollywood,
what are you telling yourself?
It sounds like you knew the odds.
Davis: So I'll give you a quick arc.
The assistant to somebody,
working small jobs 10 years.
Then I finally get my break and I sold
a script that a friend of mine wrote
to Warner Brothers, I was going
to direct it, my big break.
It was Training Day with Denzel
Washington and I got fired.
(laughs)
I got fired.
I don't even get to meet him.
I don't get to meet Denzel
Washington, I get fired.
This is my dream, this is what
I've worked towards for 10 years.
And it was for all the wrong reasons.
And I bought into this Hollywood system.
I thought if I was a good
soldier it would pay off to me
and if I did everything right and
it was going to be a great movie
and it was a great movie and I was the
only one who wanted him in the role.
And I got fired.
And I was so disillusioned, I hit rock
bottom as a person and as a director
that I said screw it and I bought
a little 800 dollar HI-8 camera
and I said I'm going to make
a movie about people I like.
And I made this film about first
year teachers called The First Year,
the first thing I ever did.
And I drove to all these public
schools all around Los Angeles
and Compton and Watts and east
L.A. and I made my first movie.
A documentary.
Voiceover: And it just felt right,
you were able to do it, and-
Davis: It was mine and the
great thing about documentaries
is you can control the
means of production.
And that was the beginning of it.
Now, all the means of production
that we use to make a documentary
can be done in my office in a way
that they couldn't have been done,
even in documentaries
only a few years earlier.
But I sort of... it was such a
devastatingly apocalyptic moment
in my life that I had no choice but
to do the thing that I had to do.
Which was tell a story about
someone I loved and admired.
Voiceover: And it was, you're saying
the documentary was an important medium
for you because you could
be in control of the story
but all of what you've done, starting
with that first documentary until now,
there's been a social justice piece of it.
In fact there's always been
this narrative of maybe
just through this documentary you might
be able to move the dial in some way.
Is that...?
Davis: Well my father had some
part of that because he did a lot
of social justice documentaries
and there is a part,
I direct a lot of television
too, which is very gratifying.
Shows like 24 and ER and
Deadwood and really gratifying.
But there's a bit of factory work to it.
My wife is on the show CSI and there's
a bit of hard work, routine work,
that the quality of the job is so
good, the people who do it are so good,
but there's something that
when I got the taste of it,
and I wanted to be a big Hollywood
director, when I got a taste of it
having told stories, made documentaries
that had some little fragment
of this film is going to not even
do good but actually have some kind
of influence on a conversation
that might do good was addictive.
And after Inconvenient Truth
which should never have been made
and I never thought would do any good-
Voiceover: Why should
it never have been made?
Davis: But after that movie
I became a junkie for it.
I'm a junkie for it.
Voiceover: Why shouldn't
it have been made?
Davis: So it was pitched
to me like they said,
these people came to me who I knew
and said here's a documentary,
what do you think?
It's a documentary about climate change.
I'm like, okay.
I'm in, I like that, I believe
that that's an important issue.
It's based on a slideshow
that Al Gore gives.
I'm like no.
Slideshow?
You can't make a movie about a slideshow.
And I have great fondness
and respect for Al Gore
but I don't think you should
make a film about a politician
because it comes with its own baggage
no matter how much you
like that politician.
Can't be done and I
said no, terrible idea.
Voiceover: So you weren't at all
enamored, I mean obviously national,
international figure, it was a hot topic.
Davis: I told them it
was a terrible idea.
Voiceover: So you'd kind
of given up on any of the,
oh this might be a super
hit or anything like that?
Davis: Even when we had finished it we
didn't think it was going to do anything.
Voiceover: But what convinced you then
to do it, to do this terrible idea?
Davis: So the producers, Laurie David and
Lawrence Bender said don't say no yet,
go to the Hilton where he's going
to do this thing at a luncheon.
And Al Gore walks on stage and I
remember this, they were serving cold,
supposed to be hot but cold chicken,
mashed potatoes and bad gravy,
and you're like sawing into your chicken.
Al Gore's like, "history of the planet,"
and I'm like lecture, slideshow,
Al Gore, terrible idea.
Really.
And the graphics were kind of
rudimentary and then by the end of it,
there was this feeling that I think
people have at the end of the movie,
which is like holy shit.
This is deep and this is urgent
and I was physically shaken.
And it's a really good lesson
I think in film-making which is
when your body feels something,
when you feel something
that you're not convincing
yourself to feel,
there's something you have to listen
to and that clever is often misleading.
I'm going to do this
movie because it's clever
or I'm going to make that
choice because it was clever,
instead of following a feeling
like a response that you have.
Trust that more than trust clever.
Voiceover: And so you were-
Davis: My chicken was like,
the gravy had dried up.
Chicken was half eaten, the fork
and the knife were left there
but I was like oh my gosh.
And even if I make this movie and 10
people see it, that's a good thing.
And I want other people to
understand what I just figured out.
So the power of it was already there
and I don't know how to do this,
it's a great thing, I
don't know how to do this,
this slideshow with a politician, it
makes no sense, but I have to do it.
So I'm driven by that overwhelming desire
that the clever side of me said do not do.
Voiceover: There wasn't a
pattern here that you could?
Davis: Oh like look up all the
very profitable documentaries
about slideshows with politicians in them.
You can't find it.
Voiceover: Do you think
about profitability when
you, even for a documentary?
Davis: No but I think about
who's going to watch it.
It's a terrible feeling and
I've had this experience
where you make a movie and no one sees it.
It's heartbreaking.
It's heartbreaking when
you work really hard
and you tell a story and no one sees it.
Voiceover: But then you do
it and it goes where frankly,
documentaries have never gone before.
It turns into a mainstream movie.
Does that change how you
perceive yourself, what you do,
what your next project was going to be?
Davis: It puts more pressure on you
when you've had a successful film
and there's sort of a
expectation on the next film.
Voiceover: That film, regardless where
someone is on the political spectrum,
that changed the discussion.
Davis: A lot of it, a huge
portion of it was Al Gore's work
in building that slideshow.
Huge part of it.
And lightning did strike, it landed
right when President George W. Bush
was starting to fall from
grace in the public's mind.
So that was helpful and people were
starting to reconsider Gore in history.
Everything that sort of...
and Katrina had just happened.
So all these things sort of fit.
The success of that
movie was not necessarily
about any of the film-making, I think it
actually had very little to do with it.
Voiceover: Well we can debate that.
Davis: The film-making worked
so the experience worked.
I'm not saying the film-making was poor.
The film-making worked.
The audience experienced what
I hoped they would experience
but its success had very little
to do with the film-making.
Voiceover: And now do you feel pressure
that you kind of have to do something
of that magnitude again or?
Davis: Not so I feel like I have
to, I'll probably never do it again
but I'm a junkie for that feeling.
Voiceover: But you kind of did it
again with Waiting for Superman.
That was another movie that really
entered the national conversation.
Davis: In a different way.
It's a more complicated experience
because it had more
controversy involved in it
but it's not about box office,
it's about feeling like
if I tell a story maybe the
conversation will change.
That's exciting.
Maybe people with this
movie will think maybe
we changed their minds about what
a teacher is, that'd be cool.
Voiceover: It's true.
It's funny I could ask you a
question that I've always wondered,
why was it called Waiting for Superman?
Where did that, was it
you, was it someone else?
Davis: So Geoffrey Canada
had this great thing...
Geoffrey Canada started this
incredible school in Harlem
and he talked about when he was a kid,
the heartbreaking moment in
his life was when he realized
Superman wasn't real, and he
was this kid in the projects.
And he thought that Superman
could come and help him
and give him some power and
save him and the day he realized
that Superman wasn't real...
And so he sort of had that
metaphor already and I didn't
come up with the title,
Lesley Chilcott the producer did.
But it was like wow, we're waiting in
the same way he was waiting for Superman.
Voiceover: And now that you've done
I mean, frankly several of these,
whether or not you admit it,
especially in certain circles
you're a household name,
is there a temptation to-
Davis: In a couple, in
like three households.
Voiceover: No, no.
Davis: You have six million
households, I got three.
Voiceover: I don't know,
well make that assumption.
Is there any temptation to go back?
There must have been a little
bit of the Hollywood movie,
the computer graphics and the real...
There's no temptation
to do Transformers 4?
Davis: I would love to do
another Hollywood movie.
I've done a couple and it'd have
to be something really special.
I wouldn't want to do Transformers 4.
It is so much work and
Michael Bay is so good at it.
Voiceover: Yeah it's not that Michael
Bay needs to be replaced or anything.
Davis: No no no but I'm saying
that's a different skill.
But I'm a junkie for that, I much
prefer to make documentaries.
Much prefer.
Voiceover: What would have to be true
about a commercial film to have you do it?
Davis: You know I watch
my kids this weekend
watch the movie 42 about Jackie Robinson.
And that did something very
different, but did something
that I love in storytelling
that they got to see a moment.
It's a true story but it's fictionalized.
But they just saw a great
story and they learned...
Learning is not the word.
They're connecting to the world.
They're connecting to the human
experience in a way in which
sometimes movies can do and when
that happens that's pretty great.
If I'm part of that, that's cool.
Voiceover: You started off
wanting to do Hollywood movies,
do you think you're inherently
better at one of the two types?
Davis: I made two feature movies
and I would call one a C minus
and the other a D plus.
Voiceover: Would you mind
saying what those movies are?
Davis: One was a movie called Gossip.
You know, it's sort of a
genre movie, it's okay.
I did a pretty good job.
The other was a movie called Gracie.
Which was, you know, it was pretty good.
Voiceover: So you weren't really
happy with how they turned out?
Davis: I think I did a pretty good job,
I think I would have like a workman's job.
I would say I'm unexceptional
as a feature director.
Voiceover: Interesting and I
know... how much time do we have?
10 minutes.
So the one thing I am fascinated and
I think I'm personally fascinated
and I hope people listening to this
would be too, you kind of glazed over
that 10 year period between
college and your first almost break
that ended up being this
thing that changed your view
of yourself and the world.
That 10 years sounds like you were
just taking whatever job you can
near a studio just to get
closer to being a principal.
Did you ever think
about giving up on that?
Davis: Yeah.
I directed a lot of episodic
television, guest directors which means
you're one of 20
directors on a given show.
When I hear about Malcolm Gladwell's
10,000 hours that rings really true to me.
There was a lot of learning
the form and repeating the form
and doing a pretty good job at the
form to then one day be better at it.
Like the Beatles playing genre tunes
that they didn't write over and
over again, three nights a week.
I learned a lot in that era.
Voiceover: So you were
getting work, so to speak.
There was a sense of progress.
Right out of college
you were able to get...
When did you get even
your first guest director?
Davis: I'm so bad at
this, dates and stuff.
So I land in L.A. in '88 and
I start directing in '93.
So five years.
Voiceover: So not too bad,
you're 26 or 27 years old.
Davis: But then you hit a certain-
Voiceover: How does that happen?
How do you even get that job?
Davis: You get your
first job paying it out,
making short films and apprenticing.
Voiceover: So you had a portfolio of
short films that you would send to people?
Davis: Yeah, kind of.
And then I would observe
on other TV shows.
Unpaid jobs standing next to directors,
pretending I knew what I was doing
and then one day someone took a-
Voiceover: How do you even get that?
You just ask?
I don't think if I called up some
random director for CSI or something,
that is like yeah, hang out with me.
How do you get there?
Davis: That took a while.
I mean part of it is
getting the low paying job
on another show and then, you know.
Voiceover: And the low
paying job is anything from-
Davis: A PA, production assistant.
Voiceover: I see and that's
something that you kind of
submitted a resume for?
Davis: Yeah and producer's
assistant and you sort of like...
The nice thing about Hollywood
is it is entrepreneurial.
You don't have to go to
graduate school or pass the bar,
you can worm your way through
the system and find a place.
Voiceover: Do you think Hollywood
eventually finds the real talent
that's out there or do you think
a lot of people get lost in this?
Davis: That's interesting.
I think talent is so rare in Hollywood.
Let me put it differently.
Scratch that.
I think there's extraordinarily
great talent in all the crafts.
Cinematographers, sound people,
art direction, wardrobe.
Incredible people.
You can find incredible people and the
depth of those people is incredible.
And the way Hollywood keeps
getting them better is incredible.
Technology, digital stuff.
But I think the part
that's really hardest,
and I think that anyone
intuitively gets this,
is the lack of great
scripts and storytelling.
That's the hardest part.
There's so few great scripts.
That they end up making more
than they have good scripts for.
Voiceover: One thing that I'm curious,
does everyone who shows up in Hollywood
and has talent, do they
eventually get found, recognized?
Davis: I think there's a
certain persistence factor,
so I'm sure there's very talented
people come and they try and fail
and then they walk away.
So that probably happens.
But if you're good and you stay for a
while and you keep banging on the door
and you're good, and you've got something
to say, I think you'll be found.
Voiceover: How do you know
you're that and not someone who's
on kind of a fool's errand?
Davis: Well that happens too.
I know a lot of people who
have written a hundred scripts
and nothing gets made and for
some reason it doesn't work.
Voiceover: Is there a clue, is
there anything you told yourself
in that 10 year period
where you were doing that?
You were being persistent?
That's a data point, that
shows that I have some talent
that I persist something
good's going to happen?
Davis: That question is
the ultimate question.
You don't know it until you see it.
And there was many many
years where I really wondered
whether I had anything at all to say.
And I for a long time felt
there was nothing to say
and I think if you said to
Davis when he was even 30 or 35,
"you think you'll ever tell
a story of any significance?"
In my heart of hearts
I would have said no.
Voiceover: Is that question the same
as do you think I'll be successful?
Davis: It's a different question.
Voiceover: Because in that early
period you were still going after
commercial Hollywood production
where success is very different then.
Davis: Yes I was a sought
after television director.
But I wasn't my own storyteller I was
in service of someone else's story.
Voiceover: I see.
So in that 10 year period you did
have a momentum to your career
that you were getting more responsibility,
more prestigious responsibilities
to direct things.
Davis: I had a chair with my name on it
and I was a member of a guild
and I made a good living.
But I wasn't doing what
I came to Hollywood to do
which is somehow tell a story.
Voiceover: How long did it take you
to get to that point where you said
well I can pay the bills with this?
Davis: Eight years.
It felt like the longest
eight years of my life.
Voiceover: So that eight years there
wasn't a period where you felt like
gee, I'm just going to stop
this, some of my friends went
and became accountants and
they can buy a nice car
and they have a down
payment on their house?
Davis: Yeah, absolutely.
So I do think there's
a persistence factor.
There's sort of like showing
up and doing the work
and knocking on 100 doors for one to open.
Voiceover: So this whole eight
year period you're just kind of
getting by but they were film
related jobs that you were doing?
Davis: Little jobs and some
of them were not paying well
and some of them were dead ends.
Voiceover: But you didn't
have to wait tables
and that type of traditional story?
Davis: I took some bad jobs.
I edited a conference for the CIA.
Voiceover: That seems interesting.
Davis: They had all the old spies come out
and talk about the Cuban missile crisis
but they're all in their 70's and 80's
and they were at a Hilton
and the sound was bad
and they were standing
at a podium and they said
here's 30 hours of footage
can you cut it down to one.
And I did that.
On paper it was a terrible job because
it was never going to go anywhere,
it wasn't going to do anything.
But on a fascination level it was great.
Voiceover: The good thing
is even in those early days
you were able to pay your bills
doing something in your craft?
It wasn't the most glamorous thing.
Davis: Barely
Voiceover: Barely, you
were able to get by.
Davis: I was a producer's
assistant for a long time.
Picking up dry cleaning,
making phone calls,
so there was a lot of grunt work.
Voiceover: And this portfolio of stuff,
this was just like you and your friends
with a camcorder that you would produce?
How were you able to do that?
Davis: I had a little bit of a
break because I worked on this film
Sex, Lies, and Videotape.
Voiceover: I remember that.
Davis: And my boss couldn't pay me
so he gave me a tenth of a point,
so a thousandth of a piece of a movie.
No, a hundredth... no a
thousandth of a movie.
A thousandth of a movie and I was
like this is a low budget movie,
no one's ever going to
see it and it turned out
to be worth 30,000
dollars in '90 something.
So I had 30,000 dollars and I
made a short film with that.
So that was like a
little gift from heaven.
Voiceover: I remember that
movie distinctly because
my uncles wanted to see it
and they were babysitting me
so they took me and my cousin
and they gave us 20 dollars in
arcade tokens in the movie theatre
and said we're going to
go watch this movie now.
Davis: And you didn't go?
Voiceover: No, I think
it was barely rated R.
Davis: Did you ever see it?
Voiceover: No I've never (Davis
laughs) I have this distinct memory
of not being allowed to see it
but I got 20 dollars in tokens
to spend the next two hours at the arcade
because my uncles wanted to see it.
Davis: They were probably
very disappointed,
it was a very deep art film with
very little fun gratuitous sex.
Voiceover: Would you pinpoint that
as kind of a break that allowed you-
Davis: That was one of the
breaks, there were a lot of...
I think luck is a part of it.
I think being ready when luck
happens is a big part of it.
Like sometimes if your luck
breaks and you're not ready,
you got to be ready when the luck happens.
The door will open but then you've got
to walk through it and do something.
Voiceover: Do you know people in Hollywood
who you just think are
the most amazing talent
and they just got squandered?
Davis: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, or sometimes they're stuck.
They're stuck working on a show
that's paying them enough money
to put their family through but they're
not doing exactly what they want to do.
It's really lucky to be able to
find something where you can tell
your own stories and have the
independence, have it all.
Sometimes it's like money and
security or doing your own thing
and having your independence.
There's always some combination
of, very few people have both.
Very few people have both.
Voiceover: And you do now though.
Davis: Probably more... documentaries
don't make... I make a good living
but not the kind of living you'd make
if you were a big Hollywood dude.
So there's a little bit of a
compromise but I picked independence
and my own stuff over big name
success and big money success.
There's always sort of a
choice between those two doors.
Voiceover: Do you ever
regret the choice you made?
Davis: I think everyone
always thinks about that,
the turn of reworking it
in their brain and I do.
I think what if I'd done
that and what if, could I?
But I think I've won the
jackpot because I love this job.
I like being where you are which is
meeting people and asking questions
and learning, the job
keeps filling you up.
And the independence to
sort of choose my stuff
and the stuff I do is pretty great.
Voiceover: Your dad's passed away now?
Davis: He saw my very first
film, that first year,
the first film that we talked about.
Voiceover: And what did he think of it?
Davis: So that was one of
the great memories I have
is we were at a screening in Washington
and I left to go to the bathroom.
It was dark and I saw him watch the
movie and he didn't see me watching him
watch the movie so I got to
see him sort of watch my movie.
And he was smiling and enjoying it
and I could tell that he liked it.
Voiceover: Did he tell
that to you later on?
Davis: No I just saw it and he
was very effusive with praise
but kids start to hear that praise
and start to not believe it.
So I got to see it, I got to see
it without him trying to praise me.
I got to feel his praise without
him having to give it to me.
Voiceover: And he was supportive
of this the whole time
that you were pursuing this?
Davis: The movie I made was not
the kind of movie he would make.
It was the opposite of what he would make,
and yet he still appreciated it.
That was the best part.
It wasn't making his movies.
Voiceover: This wasn't
a documentary this was-
Davis: It was a documentary,
it was The First Year.
It was my first-
Voiceover: This was The First
Year, the first one you had made.
You made the commercial films after that?
Davis: I made one of the commercial...
most of my television
career was before that.
Voiceover: And he'd seen
that stuff as well?
Davis: He thought it was okay. (laughs)
Voiceover: What do your
siblings do, out of curiosity?
Davis: My brother's a filmmaker and
my sister produced his documentaries.
Voiceover: So you're right, you're
right about the whole doctor thing?
Davis: Oh, it's a degenerative thing.
There's nowhere... you can't undo.
Voiceover: Not degenerate
like being a doctor's bad,
it's just that once your
parent is a filmmaker-
Davis: Right, doctors, teachers, great.
But it's hard to go back.
Maybe I'm using the wrong word.
Voiceover: Right.
Voiceover: Yeah it's limited
you to that universe.
It's not a bad universe.
Thank you, this was really fun.
Davis: It's an honor to be in your
office, sitting in your office.
Voiceover: It's an honor
to hear you say that.